this is a very sad day for Germany and
we are pretty important for everybody
the loved ones the families of those who
lost their lives it is impossible for us
to understand what happened to these
families their pain and we can only
offer our condolences to all those in
the families and loved ones I hope that
those condolences will give you a little
bit of hope and strength a suspected
far-right terrorist has shot dead 11
people near Frankfurt the shooter
opening fire at two bars in the town of
her now many of the victims are said to
have been of Turkish and Kurdish descent
the suspect is reported to have later
killed himself and his mother he has
been identified as a 43 year old German
national he left a letter admitting to
the killings and also posted a video on
YouTube expressing racist and other
extremist views federal prosecutors are
trading the attack as terrorism
the regional interior minister has
condemned the killings have a listen the
initial evaluation of the alleged
perpetrators internet page points to a
xenophobic motive I strongly condemn
this act it is an attack on our free and
peaceful society as far as we know the
suspect was neither known to the state
intelligence office as a xenophobe nor
did he have a police record and we have
team coverage of this attack here at GW
we are joined by DW political
correspondent hans brunt here in the
studio and we also have on the scene
artpad Suzy our correspondent there in
Henao and art I'd like to begin with you
what is the situation where you are
right now well it's an ongoing
investigation we have forensic
investigators combing the street here
going up the steps of the white building
behind me they found something
interesting there they have isolated
items of interest on the sidewalk and on
they've put markers there chalk around
them and these people in white outfits
going in finding things that are
supposedly going to help them in their
investigation putting the pieces
together about what happened when the
first shots fired and if you see that
cream-colored building behind me that's
where the first victim supposedly was
shot he was shot on the sidewalk
directly in front of that cream-colored
building and then the shooting continued
in the in the in the bar down the street
here and then finally at the corner of
the street another person was shot on
the sidewalk perhaps on the road not
quite clear which one which location was
exactly and then the assailant got in a
car his car which was also parked nearby
and then took off towards the other area
where the shooting spree continued okay
so that's how it unfolded witnesses
residents they have been reacting to
this attack let's have a listen and then
we'll get your reaction it's simply
unbelievable that something like this
could happen here in Hana that there are
heartless people who could simply shoot
at others who aren't involved in
anything
soon a murder in vehicles in England it
was like a massacre a rampage there was
blood everywhere people on the ground it
was like a massacre one witness saying
there also that sense of fear being
articulated art this attack taking place
overnight how now reacting this morning
what have you been hearing on the
streets well they just can't understand
that something like this could actually
happen here I mean it's an area with
it's a town a city small city a hundred
thousand that has its problems a lot of
people have to work two jobs because the
salaries aren't very high here and so
they you know they need to have jobs to
make ends meet there's a there's a drug
problem here and
basically people still get along
together I mean one of the witnesses I
talked to he's of Turkish descent but I
mean he grew up here and he said
occasionally you know you get some
comments from somebody who might have
had too much to drink about their
ethnicity or something like that but you
let it go basically people get along
people are desperate today about about
what happened here and as we heard in
that last statement by one of the one of
the people being interviewed what's
going to happen in the future like how
do you go on how do you prepare yourself
do you go into a bar and wonder is the
guy going to come in here and shoot the
place up I mean it's it's it's
insecurity now that's that's what it
feels like Germany a country that has
invited so many people in and made homes
for so many people who were in need
all of a sudden again unfortunately
another incident has happened where
deaths have occurred out of hatred 11
people dead this morning Hans our
political correspondent here in the
studio I'd like to turn to you you know
the obvious next question is why why did
this happen
authorities investigators have been
informing us in fact this morning in
terms of what they know yes I think what
is clear now and what the authorities
have said is that there is a right-wing
terrorist background to this attack that
the man who presumably committed these
murders was someone who was very
immersed in a right-wing extreme
right-wing conspiracy theories talking
about foreigners flooding into Germany
and the need to stop this from happening
talking about some sort of secret to
control being exercised other people in
Germany other people in the United
States over the world these kind of
conspiracy theories are things that he
expressed in a written statement that
was found in German in very good German
apparently and also in a video on
YouTube which was in English where he
was addressing himself obviously to
Internet to an international audience
and to an American audience in fact he
mentioned the
United States of America particularly so
it's clearly a racist motive that is the
background to this an attack on people
of immigrant background in Germany and
it's not the first attack that we have
seen motivated by you know these these
far-right sentiments in Germany in the
past year in fact just walk us through
what has been happening in the country
and and whether this appears to be a new
wave here
yes I think you can say that the number
of right-wing incidents of right-wing
violence has increased in recent months
and years within the last year they've
been three fatal attacks one was on a
conservative politician
ljubka who was murdered by a right-wing
extremist someone who had been in
support of integrating migrants in
Germany the other attack was an
anti-semitic attack on a synagogue in
the town of Halle in October there were
two people killed on the street outside
the synagogue there and then we had this
attack here yesterday late last night
with eleven victims in total but these
are just the worst incidents the German
authorities are saying that there are
somewhere around a thousand incidents of
right-wing violence every year in other
words it's a daily occurrence
and that's only right-wing violence if
you then talk about right-wing crimes
such as support for forbidden
organizations such as the spraying of
swastikas on tombstones those kinds of
things then we are talking about close
to well well over 10,000 incidents a
year so it's something that's happening
pretty much daily in Germany but has not
really perceived very hadn't been
perceived so clearly I think until now
and we're gonna talk about how
authorities have been dealing with that
Hans but in the meantime I want to go in
fact to a security expert who we have on
the line I know you're gonna stick
around with us we have Yan st. Pierre
security expert and counterterrorism
adviser joining us from Frank where we
know that this attack we're 11 people in
Germany were killed overnight in henow
is near Frankfurt in fact so Yan st.
Pierre you know with that in mind with
that context you have some in for me
about the letter that Hans referenced
and the video of the alleged perpetrator
what more can you tell us about that
well essentially he he he goes very
different ways invokes different
theories but the core message is
essentially one that is used in a key a
conspiracy theory that of the great
emplacement that there's a huge
international conspiracy to replace
Western people from their own lands by
an influx of migrants and this theory
has been very growing actually since
2011 and of course following the refugee
crisis in 2015 has gained more ground
because a lot of people feel vindicated
by using this theory they say well see
this is fruitful were we're being
invaded and our authorities are allowing
it and this is aside from a lot of the
more frivolous conspiracy theories this
is essentially the redline the thread
behind his messages both Britain and the
video messages online can you expand on
this idea of sparking a race war yes
well that's that's the idea of the the
great replacement is that to avert this
great replacement people will need to
stand up and fight and resist and by any
means necessary
and in this case we see this is the the
idea that private was invoking oh sorry
Christchurch was I'm a possum southern
Quebec City we saw again in Halle last
year this is the idea that authorities
can no longer be trusted
with the defense of the so-called
homeland and as such citizens and people
who believe in the true values of the
country must stand up what must rise up
and defend the country and this is the
mentality that has also fueled a lot of
the
malicious that have been slowly growing
across Germany over the last cent or two
three four years
you mean you mentioned militias that
implies some level of organization in
fact behind these mantras these
ideologies so tell us I mean when we
look at this individual attacker the one
in her now last night
what sort of clues are you looking about
with regard to his preparation and what
would have been necessary for this level
of attack could he have been acting
alone I look at I look at two aspects
especially in the new face which is very
important because a big mistake by live
Western authorities but it's very
prominent in Germany is that we tend to
use former analytical templates to
assess a terrorist attack and that a
template does not involved or imply a
digital social life and what we've seen
over the last few years is that a lot of
these so-called loners that we would
assume in that past era would be
considered lone wolves actually have
very active lives online
get support from a lot of people have a
very well-established network and this
is where we would I would be looking to
see this guy is did not act alone he
actually had in various ways a lot of
support and then the other way around is
okay what's the you know a lot of
terrorists active in areas that within
which they're familiar this means the
key question is where and how did he get
the record this is the main issue so
those two elements are probably key to
finding out how everything went on okay
and for those who have been following
the news here in Germany in fact in the
past week perhaps we can just to remind
people you know it comes at this this
attack it's coming after raids were
conducted on potential far-right militia
here in Germany last week do you see any
connections here just to listen on
what's going on
well they D the connection is the fact
that more and more people are getting
involved in these these groups and more
and more people are willing to act
violently on a lot of these ideas and
grievances and the fact that we see
these groups formally organizing using
what whatsapp group or Facebook group as
well as classical more more isolated
figures like the the
per trader of last night's attack coming
together and acting on their own I think
is symptomatic of a broader situation
where we lived in their polarized
society within societies where the
political discourse focuses very much on
fear and people react to this and I
think we're soon some some of the side
effects of this focus on security and
people are willing to act on them
so this would be the link between
militias and lone actors young
saint-pierre security expert and
counterterrorism adviser joining us
there from Frankfurt thank you so much
thank you
and just to remind our viewers we are
following this breaking news of
far-right extremists shooting dead 11
people in Germany that happened
overnight
Hans Brandt our political correspondent
joining us here in the studio for some
analysis on this this attack didn't
appear to come out of nowhere or did it
well in the the the concrete attack came
out of nowhere yes indeed nobody
expected this person to commit such an
act he was not on the radar of any of
the security agencies he was not known
to the police as someone who potentially
might have committed such an actor who
was involved in groups that were
preparing this kind of violence but at
the same time you have to see is it to
say that the political situation in
Germany is such that right-wing
sentiment is growing has been growing
and that the number of attacks the
number of people that are prepared to be
involved in such attacks the number of
right-wing extremist groups that are
organizing themselves has increased
significantly at the same time one hears
criticism again and again for instance
our voiced today by the Jewish
organization the Council of Jewish
organizations in Germany that the
authorities so far have not taken enough
note of right-wing terror that they have
concentrated their anti-terror
organization their anti-terror
activities against Muslim organizations
and possibly against far left wing
terror suspects but that the right-wing
has not really been in their focus
enough that I think
changing and now in this particular case
apparently federal prosecutors have have
been brought in in order to handle the
investigation what does that say to you
well federal prosecutors in Germany only
take on such cases if there is an a
significance that goes beyond the region
in which the attack took place in other
words beyond the federal set of HESA
where this attack took place it has to
be an attack that has potential of
attacking the German state as it were
and the fact that the Tara fatal
prosecutor has taken over this case
is an indication that the authorities
treat this as an act of terrorism what
more do we know about the alleged
perpetrator he's a 43 year old man from
hanno from the city where this attack
took place he was born there he went to
school there he studied somewhere
outside town he was someone who was
involved in somewhere in a financial
business he described himself as a
banking expert on his personal website
and it seems that he did have a very
very meager social life some of the
security experts who have analyzed his
writings and his video in the last few
hours have said that he is someone that
can be reckoned to be an in cell that is
this group of white men the so-called
involuntary celibates the the white
young men or not so young men who do not
have contact with women who feel that
they have been pushed aside by women who
do not have really relationships who
don't have a proper social life and see
he seems to have been someone like that
lived with his mother whom he killed
last night as well seems to have had his
social life mainly online mainly in some
sort of conspiracy theory kind of
circles in the internet what are the
authorities you think going to be
focusing on as we move forward we have
to accept or we have to reckon that that
the authorities are several hours ahead
of us then a lot more than we know at
the moment they know for instance about
his right-wing sentiments since some
time during the night when they raided
his flat his
apartment and found his body and the
body of his mother so they're trying to
follow up these leads they're trying to
see which chat rooms he was involved in
what kind of organizations or groups or
people he was in contact with in the
Internet online whether any of them
aided him helped him in this attack
whether they knew about this attack and
for instance did not warn the
authorities so they're trying to find
out what exactly the context was in
which he committed this crime and
whether there are other people there
that need to be prosecuted that need to
be arrested that need to be questioned
and they are very careful about letting
out any of this detailed information so
that there's possible other people
involved are not warned are not given
warning so that they can kind of hide
their tracks or withdraw and as that
work is taking place we've actually had
some reaction from the state premier of
HESA that is the German state where
Hanau is located he has expressed his
condolences the families and friends of
the victims and we're gonna have a
listen to what he said and then get
reaction today is a day of mourning a
day of horror so please understand that
we are all also in a very personal level
trying to come to terms with what has
happened in summary I would like to say
that the thoughts of all the people of
the state of Hesse er
are with the victims in Hanau and with
their relatives and may this empathy
offer comfort to them this most
difficult may this empathy offer comfort
to them let's bring back our
correspondent art Susy who is standing
by for us in her now in the field there
are those words likely to offer comfort
to the people that you've been speaking
with art well that's the most the
government can do at this stage until
they get to the bottom of this and did
someone perhaps mess up and not see
signs was this person more active than
we think we don't know yet but uh people
appreciate any kind of any kind of
condolences and support moral support
that they can get here because they are
extremely upset extremely shocked
that something like this could happen
this was just not on the radar screen of
anyone I mean this it's it's a city that
has its problems but I mean it's a city
that provides life and homes and
friendships and relationships between
people and and they go to a sports bar
where they think they're going to have
some fun and watch a Champions League
game and not dream that somebody's going
to come in and shoot up the place so or
tell us a little bit more about this
town then and and about the people that
you've been speaking with there what
you've been seeing out on the streets
right right well it's a blue-collar town
it has some industry especially the
chemical industry and it also has a big
tire factory here from Dunlop and and
basically you know it's but the salaries
aren't high so a lot of these are are
semi skilled jobs and there's some
skilled jobs too but a lot of people
have two jobs just to make ends meet and
pay the bills things like that but I
mean it's a very functioning City it has
a high immigrant population - first and
foremost from Turkey people from Turkey
who came here or are descendants of
Turkish immigrants then from the former
Yugoslavia and then more recently Syria
Afghanistan and Ethiopia's was explained
to me by one taxi driver so I mean
that's the background but I mean people
got along I had one gentleman witness
actually - what had partial witness to
what had happened he told me that he's
of Turkish descent but he grew up here
occasionally you would encounter someone
who's had too much to drink and then
they would tell him what they thought of
him but I mean you let it go he told me
he said it wasn't a big thing and he
never really experienced a big problem
ever in his 38 years I believe he's 38
years old so he it's a shock to everyone
that something like this could happen a
mass slaughter a mass shooting